what is the Burning Man temple and what
do you remember about your experiences
there the temple the temple I mean the
temple is a piece of art in itself and
like the man it also burns so on
saturday night we burn the man massive
fireworks display huge celebration party
atmosphere fire that saturday night on
sunday night the temple burns and the
temple burns in complete silence so
there's a good 20,000 people that come
together and observe the temple burning
and it's and basically that's sort of
the result of the week the week is you
know monday through sunday and on sunday
night the temple burns and you know the
temple is a place that's different for
each person i think some people view the
temple is like where they can really
acknowledged loved ones that have maybe
passed away or maybe past experiences
that they'd like to you know no longer
have be part of their lives a lot of
people will write love letters or put a
piece of put a piece of art into the
temple so that it gets burned too so a
piece of clothing a piece of art some
photographs a letter anything that
you're wanting to let go of it's sort of
like you know a way of sort of like
acknowledging that that happened but
acknowledging that maybe it doesn't have
to hold you back anymore or you know the
pain of someone passing away can now be
acknowledged the right way and it's
fascinating it's it's you know being
there with so many people in silence it
feels so honorable it feels so
respectful it feels like something
that's like a real ceremony and yeah you
know it comes down and people will go
about at their own way and I think
that's part of the Burning Man thing is
to kind of like you decide you decide
the meaning of it you decide what it
means you know a lot of people will ask
Larry Harvey what is the man mean what's
the significance of the man
and Larry always answers a different
answer each time because you know it's
up its up to the people who go there to
decide what it means and decide how
their experiences is it going to be
you